so the title of my talk today is
understanding CSS custom properties and
the reason that it is called this is
it's kind of based on a talk that I gave
in a blog post that I wrote previously
which was a strategy guide to CSS custom
properties I mean I encourage you to
have a look at that if you want a little
bit more detail about what I'm speaking
about tonight but the truth is I like my
slide deck at home so I've recreated
this with what I had online and stuff
and we're going without notes today so
hopefully this goes alright I want to
give you a quick demo firstly of what we
can do we CSS custom properties was that
film Nash in the background by the way
he's also from Australia I'm gonna call
him out and get him to pick tonight's
color scheme
pick a color fill for your primary yeah
I thought so
now do you remember that do you remember
the hex number anyone is it like let's
just pick green it's kind of blueish
green right yes have been nice to him
Phil what do you want is your secondary
color mate say you again Christ we don't
even enter a hex thing can you give me a
HSL mate you're getting hot pink okay
that's what's happening all right so you
can see that the custom properties have
been written down here and this is this
is genuinely happening in the browser at
the moment we're just writing this to
like a style tag and this is actually
affecting the slides and you can see
it's already affected the title of this
slide and hopefully the title of the
slides that come as well
so that's kind of how they work I want
to give you a little bit more detail
about how they work but I'm not going to
focus too much on the syntax
I'm just very briefly there they're not
really like variables but they sort of
are and you probably know that we use a
dollar sign to denote a variable incest
and unless we use an @ symbol and custom
properties have a similar convention
they have a dash dash prefix but you'll
notice two other small differences there
and that is that they're contained
within a CSS selector in this case the
root selector and we will talk more
about that in a moment but also there's
a different syntax for assigning a value
to a custom property then there is for
retrieving that value so when we're
retrieving the value of a custom
property we use that little var function
there and that should be familiar to
people of use like Calcutta min max or
other sort of color functions or any of
those more functional parts of CSS that
are making their way into the modern
language so hopefully that's not too
confusing the other difference is that
preprocessor variables can be used
almost anywhere and this means that they
can be used like in breakpoints
selectors values basically anywhere and
there's a whole bunch of examples here
where you can see like I'm writing out
like the selectors variable here and I'm
using it as a value and I'm using it in
them in an app rule and all these
examples would be invalid if we were
using custom properties so custom
properties can be used anywhere that
normal CSS properties are valid and that
basically means between these curly
braces here so you can see again we've
assigned that to a particular selector
between those curly braces and that also
can be used inside like a media rule as
well so we can change the value of the
same custom property in different
contexts within the same page and that
really is the key difference so just
take note of that so similarly that vast
statement can be used anywhere that
normal CSS values are valid and what
that means is that they can be used as
single values in shorthand statements
they can even be used inside calc and
color functions and things like that so
you can see there's an example of a
signing of a single value to a color I'm
using it as a shorthand for the right
margin there and I'm also using it in a
calc equation here to apply padding so
there's lots of different ways you can
use CSS variables and if you're thinking
about the VAR statement all you have to
remember is is it somewhere with I can
put a normal CSS value or a unit type
thing and that pretty much ends my crash
course on CSS custom properties it's
probably a whole lot more that you want
to know but that should be enough to
sort of to help you with the rest of the
talk I guess so cosmetic differences
aside the most significant difference
between preprocessor variables
and custom properties is that custom
properties are dynamic so you possibly
have some idea what like dynamic
variables mean and what static variables
mean but as far as pre processes are
concerned what what's static so
preprocessor variables are static custom
properties are dynamic so static as far
as pre-processors is concerned means
that the value of the variable can
change but it's not going to update
anything anywhere else in the page or
anywhere when that browser changes so
what that means is I can set the
background variable here to read and
then it'll be output as read so this is
the this is the this as CSS this is the
CSS that gets generated and again I can
change it to blue it's not changing the
one above then variables sometimes do
behave like that if they're dynamic
depending on depending on the language
and how they use but basically with
preprocessors you should be able to read
an entire CSS file and if you've got
enough patience you should be able to
work out exactly what the output is
without needing to know any other
context about the HTML the device or
anything else like that and that is not
the case with custom properties so as
I've said already custom properties are
dynamic and where CSS is concerned emic
dynamic means that their scope to
selectors and subject to inheritance and
the Cascade and I just want to give you
a little like visual example of what
that means we've kind of already seen it
but if I apply this CSS here you can see
that the color of my slide heading my
primary color has been updated to tomato
and you can see that that's affected
every slide but I can of course change
this here and I can just say I think
this is what I called it yes I can just
say like the only this dynamic slide and
that is now only affecting this
particular example here so that's kind
of what dynamic means with custom
properties and we'll show you some more
examples of that as we go through as
well okay so in addition to to being
sort of like dynamic or static custom
properties up and variables can also be
global or local and again if you if you
write JavaScript you'll know what I mean
here variables can either be applied to
sort of everything within an application
or their scope can be limited to
civic functions or blocks of code and
custom properties are kind of the same
so by default custom properties are
scoped locally to the selectors that we
apply them to so they're kind of like
local variables the custom properties
are also inherited and you'll know what
this means if you've done things with
like font properties or color or any
other thing that you want to force to
inherit in CSS and that means that like
when we're looking for the VAT
retrieving the value of a custom
property and there's not custom property
assigned to that particular selector
it's going to walk up the Dom and find
the nearest parent that has that
particular custom property and it's
going to inherit that value from there
and that means that custom properties
are kind of global as well and
especially when we apply custom
properties to the route selector which
is a very common pattern you see in a
lot of examples including some of mine
but it's not really a pattern that I
would suggest you use to widely okay I
love when I put the microphone on my
throat and you can all hear me swallow
so this idea of like global and local
variables and stuff is not just like
limited to code there's like global and
local things in design as well and if
you look at any design system and this
is just like a wide screenshot of the
material design system you'll see like
consistency in terms of colors sizes
shapes so design has things that are
global and things that are local as well
so some of the local things are like the
button size variations whether like an
avatars on the left or the right of a
component these are local things that
like change from component to component
and then you have like global things
that you want applied like consistently
across your application right you want
your spacing and your typography and all
of that hopefully to be consistent so as
it turns out most global things in
design most global things in CSS are
also static right your typography
doesn't change from one build to the
next typically definitely doesn't change
from one component to the next maybe
there's a few little exceptions but
typically you want these things fairly
consistent and they can change but where
it does happen it tends to
like a global redesign and not something
that happens regularly with a mature
product and for that reason I think that
you should consider using pre processes
for static variables and aside from
helping keep like those dynamic and
Static concerns separate visually
denotes them in your code and that makes
your CSS a whole lot easier to read and
therefore easier to maintain as well so
don't necessarily just jump to it
because you can so you might think that
given my fairly strong stance on that
last thing about all global things being
static and remember when I say static I
mean pretty much pre processes you might
think that okay well if all global
things are static by reflection all
local things should be dynamic and yes I
agree kind of that tendency is nowhere
near as strong as the tendency for
global things to be static and I think
that it's perfectly okay to have locally
static variables sometimes and
particularly in the case of like complex
UI components but of course complex UI
components don't make fantastic slides
so I've got the simplest version of that
that I can which is a bunch of buttons
with different sizes again pretty lazy
of me really but basically you can see
that like just as a developer
convenience I've got three variables
here that dictate the different sizes
and I'm using them on different classes
there to get those different sizes
you're probably all done something like
this before now obviously this would
make a lot more sense if we were using
these variables more than once
it would make even more sense if we were
deriving padding and margin or using
like you know pre-processors to do maths
or something like that so yeah obviously
that makes more sense but you can do it
like this too and something like that I
think it's perfectly fine to have
preprocessor variables and I like to
prefix them with the component name so
they and know that these are local
variables you can use any prefix you
like or you can choose to prefix your
global variables but for me it helps to
know that these are local static
variables because the most of my static
variables in my code if I'm using custom
properties are going to be more global
in nature that apocrypha that the
constants things like that maybe you'll
capitalize them find some way to
differentiate them I think is the point
that I'm trying to make now I want you
to imagine a situation where
on a small screen or a mobile device you
always want to use the small variation
and then like above say 800 pixels you
want them to use these sizes here so
like no matter whether you've used the
large class on a small screen it's just
always going to be small and suddenly we
have like a more dynamic situation right
and in that case I think it makes sense
to continue using this and this might be
a pattern you use if you're like
refactoring code where you make these
like locally static varo variables into
dynamic local variables and I want you
to have a little look at this example
here I know everyone said hates writing
code but let me explain it I have one
custom property here called button size
I assign all of my buttons the value of
button small now you might be wondering
what's this little hash and the curly
braces in sass that means I want you to
output the value of this variable
instead of doing anything with that
variable because you only need this in
special cases and it just so happens
that the value of dollar BTN - SML is a
valid custom property value so I don't
know why you would use it but you can
write that in CSS so this just tells us
I want you to output the value of that
variable so now we can ignore that so
we've got a custom property that's
assigning a size of small initially then
above 800 pixels what we're saying is
for the button medium in the button
large I want you to use this other
property here we're changing the value
of the same custom property at no point
yet have we used that custom property
it's not until down here on the button
class which is applied to every button
that I'm using or retrieving the value
of that custom property and that will no
because it's scoped the variables are
different depending on the other classes
that are on those buttons so what we
kind of have here is a separation of
like the logic component and the in the
declarative code for styling CSS and
this is just an introduction to that
example we'll begin to make more sense
in a moment but I want to take a little
bit of a breather now a little bit of a
diversion and remind people to not be
too clever so this is an example of some
code that I saw in an article by Bill
soya on the free code camp medium and I
kind of love it it's like it creates an
array it loops over a bunch of numbers
basically and then pushes like a cow
acta code converted to a string into the
array to get the letters of the alphabet
right and it's small and it's concise
nobody's faster than typing out all the
letters of the alphabet by hand
especially since we have like a lot of
Chinese speakers here as well I imagine
that would take a long time right yeah
um so it's cool but like in production
I'd much rather have something like this
right because the fact is we've read
code far more often than we write it and
I want to see what's inside that
variable immediately so something like
this makes more sense to me in a
production setting and the same thing
can be said for custom properties as
well now when custom properties were new
someone sent me this example and I was
like ah yeah that's awesome and for
about like an hour it was awesome and
I'll quickly explain it actually so
because custom properties run in the
browser at runtime this is generating
like a modular scale which is like a
series of numbers that relate to each
other does anyone use modular scales
before they're just imagine headings
that sort of get larger and the rate at
which they get large it gets larger as
they get larger and makes so much sense
okay and so basically what it's doing is
its multiplying this ratio by the value
of the previous custom property to step
up in the scale right you don't have to
you don't have to like understand how
that works but what you do have to
understand is how cool it is that I can
just change the value of the ratio and
all of those other values will be
updated automatically so I can switch
from a 1.2 ratio for my heading sizes to
a 1.33 ratio and that's cool but then I
realized that in production once again
I'd much rather something a little bit
more like this right so again I want to
be able to read those values by all
means I think that you should experiment
and do things like the previous example
but in production maybe consider
something like this now this isn't
perfect as well because it violates the
rule earlier that sort of global things
should be static and I feel like these
are like kind of global so I'd much
rather use preprocessor variables for
this as well and then convert them to
like locally dynamic properties using
the method that I showed you with the
button
before so and what the other reason for
it is basically when you have something
like this you can end up doing a thing
where you go from using font size 1 to
font size you know 2 to font size 3
inside media queries and that's really
not how custom properties should be used
that's how static variables are used so
I want to say be careful of familiar
patterns right so here we've got an
example of like a font size smaller font
size large and then initially we're
applying the small size and then we're
using a media query and we're applying
the large size right that's exactly what
you would do with sass and this is
typically the wrong thing to do with
custom properties what you want to do
with custom properties just change the
value not the variable and what that
means is this right so we have an
example class again we're applying the
example font size we have a variable
called exhibit scope that that custom
property belongs to that selector and
then we update the value of this same
custom property using a media query and
then we only have to retrieve that value
once once again we've got that
separation here where the code where we
apply the custom properties and the code
where we sort of like declare all of the
logic that relates to them do people
sort of see the difference there that
I'm demonstrating a few nods ok so I'm
running out of time I just want to
quickly talk about custom properties for
responsive design because it relates
kind of to the previous example one
thing you can do is if you're using a
media query or anything to update the
value of a normal CSS property then
maybe that thing should be a custom
property stick it in a custom property
move it up to the top of the page along
with all of the rest of your logic that
changes the value of that property and
then down the bottom you'll have like
one place where you use all of your
variables and if done correctly this
means that media queries should only be
used to update custom properties and
this is if you take this to the extreme
it sort of feels a bit weird at first
but it's actually really nice and what
it does is it helps you separate the
logic from the designer I've come up
with this metaphor that I feel like a
logic bulb which is like I'll show you
what it is so basically in this example
here this is the code that would be like
above-the-fold what I'm talking about
when I keep doing this
and that means that we have like in this
example I'm creating like a grid type
system here and I'm praying a row which
initially is set to display:block and
then using a media query I'm setting its
display to flex which will mean that
like any flex properties that I've
applied to it will come into effect so
basically a grid system that starts off
full width all the time and then above
800 pixels that applies the logic and
then below the fold we have the logic so
you can see that there's no media
queries here
here I'm using applying the value of the
custom properties and what I can do now
is I can look and see any way that I've
used a vast statement I immediately know
that that is a value that's going to
change and with previous methods of
writing CSS there wasn't really no way
of knowing this right you have to I'm
sure many of you got very good at
reading and understanding CSS on the fly
and keeping track of things in your head
I don't want to be good at that like and
it's amazing how good some of us got at
it so basically what it results in is
like this highly decorative code below
the fold that's kind of like the CSS
that we used to write before media
queries and before a lot of the
complexities of the modern language and
it feels really nice and I can switch
between examining like the logic of my
application or the logic of my
components to examining okay what styles
and what variables are being applied and
that separation is really nice and it
actually makes CSS a whole lot easier to
read and maintain as well and one of the
big advantages is it makes things easy
to delete as well so all of those are I
think huge advantages to using CSS in
this way okay one and a half minutes I'm
going to talk about theming so the--my
is kind of the exception to the rule I
was saying before that like all global
things should be static I'm going to
give a caveat for theming so theming I
mean like changing the value of the
colors on your slide deck for example or
on your Twitter profile or like updating
the profile picture these are all
examples of like theming things that are
individual to different users of your
application so I think that we should
capitalize global custom properties if
we're using like if you're theming
something you can use the route selector
you can say okay this is the thing that
I want across my entire application and
I'm going to say my default theme color
here is tomorrow
and then I'm going to do this and I'm
sorry that wrapped hang on a sec yeah so
what I'm doing here is I'm setting the
value of theme color to the value of
user theme color if it exists and the
second value inside the VAR statement is
a fallback value so what that means is
here I'm saying the theme color is user
theme color or tomato if it doesn't
exist and then what we can do is we can
for each individual user we can just say
the user's theme color is in this case
Rebecca purple and then I say the
background is theme color which will
inherit from here and then the value
will be updated does that make sense to
people
so basically what that allows is you can
say I have a deep am i at a time alright
well that's it I was on my last slide
now you notice the second half of that
talk might have been a little bit
sketchy and this is what I was doing
today instead of working on my talk and
there's another video where like I
absolutely nailed it triple backflip but
this is the one you're getting alright
thanks so much
[Applause]